oh here it is okay oh dear
uh oh wait there's there's pawns
there's pawns that are not meant to be
here eric what's your favorite letter in
your first name
my favorite letter my first name
probably i because that's me
also what is this position why are there
pawns so
close to the edge also at least it's
symmetrical so i'm not like losing on
the spot
i should probably take the queen
otherwise
yeah otherwise i'll beat down the queen
the question is which pawn to take with
probably this pawn
okay this will be interesting
so white's probably slightly better with
extra tempo
oh this position makes andrew chess
uncomfy
this is a definition of uncomfy
what is this position wait what was on
a6 oh that was a rook
well the brook is going to be trapped
anyway so i'm probably better off
not taking the rook
probably taking another bishop ha ha
oh cole coles may be listening
to be careful what i say it's a very
confusing position
let's take this thing
okay so now it's a bit more asymmetrical
i feel like the first at least the first
10 moves will all be captures
so if if agon mata were to review this
game
he'd just started out with captures
captures captures captures captures
captures captures captures captures
captures captures captures captures
etc
i'm pretty sure there there was like a
an super fan
that said captures 50 000 times
on the live stream recently if i'm not
mistaken
yay whole year love all let's try and
find the work you do to improve it for
us
oh thanks so much gay bow tie i
appreciate that
i think the name is
captures oh here we go wait a hundred
thousand captures
oh dear like the mr beast of chess
okay
let's capture this
wow look at this look at this
oh wow
so this is part two this captures
captures captures
sculptures captures captures captures
captures captures captures captures
captures captures captures captures
captures capture this is the live stream
captures captures captures captures
captures captures captures captures
captures capture
part two just captures captures captures
couples cup just captures cup just
i don't think i'll do that ever unless
it's maybe for like charity
wow respect
it's got to take a toll on the vocal
cords i would think
trying to think if i were to say a word
a hundred thousand times in a row what
word would that be
oh it took him how long did it take it
took just over eight hours
for fifty thousand should we watch let's
watch the finale
okay oh opponent one connect four
wow white's dangerously close to like
queening and mating me
which is kind of scary
i think i want to take the bishop
because the bishop actually has
influence
oh there's a cool idea though
wait a minute i could take this thing
wait we both have
the same idea right so
captures captures captures captures
doesn't quite work
but if i captures like this
let's start with this i like this we'll
see which way
oh oh i could say tagi i could say tagi
50 000 times
or maybe just twice taggy toggy
look at this pictures
couches wow
oh he's he's really slowing he's he's
slow playing it
wow the capture skips captures
cap chutz captures
captures captures this has ten thousand
views on youtube
captures captures oh antonio got engaged
oh so this was like an engagement
presence
captures opponent's still thinking
okay this is what i was hoping for
because now captures captures captures
ooh
this knight is in trouble wait can pawns
still okay pawns can still
i guess take diagonally even when
they're on the first rank
good to know
so i'm attacking the knight wait i might
just be winning here
white could play a non-captures and
defend defending through x-ray vision
i'm expecting a non-captures move from
white in this position
yeah i think there's only two moves
that don't get mated instantly maybe
three moves
or four moves but somehow this worked
out
so what white should have done white
should have taken with this pawn
um if white took with this pawn then
after it takes takes
takes uh i wouldn't be queening because
my pawn would be
blockaded and then i could move to c3
i'm very curious what stockfish will say
especially about the starting position
or maybe it will just break sockfish
i could say hello i feel like thank you
would be
would be a nice word to say we'll see
now that's why you take towards the
center especially when you have a pawn
on a1
because now this pawn isn't doing
anything
so there's yeah there's a lot of people
that that want a game
i think the next next game will be
random hello future me watching on
youtube
hello to future bicycle i have to
remember to to post this
i have to do some some post game
analysis
yeah this is the best try but now
captures
make a queen white has two legal moves
could still take some work to eventually
mate let's take with check
so i'm still keeping up the capture
streak
every move i've played so far has still
been a capture
i'll keep it that way and probably want
to take the rook soon
ooh why wants the queen as well
am i scared
no let's um i'll take towards the center
learning from my opponent's mistake
hey it's double b i met a fellow chess
player on rocket league the other day
with the username too
wow key2 and it made my day
that's funny i still don't know what
rocket league is
but some kind of like
some kind of competitive maybe
space game okay so the rook is saved
hmm i guess i could take a knight
yeah i just got to take all the free
stuff maybe
i should have probably taken this way
but that's okay life is still good
it's a soccer car game what
so where are there rockets involved
is a car with rockets playing soccer wow
i would have had
no clue that's fascinating
i feel like soccer should like be in the
title
like soccer league
okay let's keep taking stuff
hey it's v2 or v-toe
subbing with prime thanks so much
is there rocket basketball
or rocket tennis
i could google it but it's more
entertaining when the chat
tries to explain
alexa what's rocket league
according to wikipedia rocket league is
a vehicular soccer video game developed
and published by psyonix
the game was first released for
microsoft windows and playstation 4 in
july 2015
with ports for xbox one and nintendo
switch being released later on
june 2016 505 games began distributing
the physical retail version for
playstation 4
and xbox one with warner brothers
sounds very vehicular
[Music]
that's a great word
okay the captures continue
every move i've played so far has been
captured
but can i keep it going hmm
captures
[Music]
i'm realizing i like the only pieces i
really have are the knights
the two knights and the queen okay i
could play queen c2
when the rook
yeah no more captures let's uh
let's get this over with
i was gonna run out eventually
sorry chat okay i'll keep capturing
pawns
it'll come with check man these pawn
these pawns on the eighth ring they're
so
like they give me a headache just
looking at
yes as reserve atom rose and rocket
league is the sequel to supersonic
acrobatic rocket-powered battle cars
really or ssa rbpbc for short
obviously rocket league is a catchier
name of their marketing manager should
get a raise
um yeah it's very important when naming
things
that you you simplify the name
as much as possible just so it's easier
to say
you can build a brand around it
i have two possible captures both losing
a queen
goodbye youtube no more every move is a
capture video
oh yeah oh
i messed up the youtube title
i mean this is still like a worthy
youtube thumbnail kind of
okay now i can capture
i guess that wouldn't be possible in
normal chess
where every move is a capture you can't
capture
you can't capture on the first move i
guess starting on move two you could
capture everything
hmm
so i wanted to do this in mate but the
pawn covers e2
it's a nice defensive pawn
oh yeah i would have to try sarawan
chess
it's s chess ass standing for sarawan
there's a site where you can play it
alright
good game coal that's a that was a weird
position
game
i i would imagine white should be better
but i'm not sure about how much
so sockfish is just broke
this position broke stockfish maybe that
can be the youtube video title
good game man lmao realized i had a
winning move right at the start oh
did you what if i press if i press
spacebar
spacebar usually makes some the move for
stockfish
but it's not suggesting any moves
because i don't think
it can really understand pawns on the
first rank
let's see what uh what this says
no it's it's not even suggesting moves
so just it oh oh if i click this
ah interesting so it's kind of broken
but kind of still working
and somehow white is up 88
close to 88 wow 88 or 12.
it's still a pretty big advantage
if i played queen takes e4 at the start
i think i would have just won
queen takes e4 oh
that's an interesting move but i i can
copy you
so i mean white definitely has an
advantage because
white's moving first and so many things
are hanging
um but maybe it's not super simple
yeah the key mistake this game was
this moment
wait white's still okay here
oh i viking counter attack
ah wait
what if i take
can i move
i don't think stockfish understands this
position as it goes from eight plus
90 or plus 76
we play the we play the best move
how is white better here
even if i took with the other pawn you
had queening ideas i think
didn't you
okay so i was basically playing against
stockfish
so it fluctuated from like plus 80 to
now minus nine and it still says plus
what is this sockfish is just terribly
confused
it's completely broke yeah